la scène se déroule en plein cœur du
Musée National Gallery à Londres ces
militantes écologistes viennent de jeter
de la soupe à la tomate sur le tableau
les tournesols
œuvre mondialement connues de Van Gogh
[Musique]
un acte symbolique pour dénoncer la
situation de millions de familles au
bord du gouffre face à l'inflation ce
geste vient s'ajouter à un mois d'action
du groupe justopproil déjà bien connu
pour ce type de coup d'éclat ces
activistes demandent la raie immédiat de
tout nouveau projet pétroliers ou gazier
bon bien sûr il y avait une vitre
non si c'est toucher le symbole
simplement et comme il y a une vitre
et d'ailleurs la justice anglaise sera
très clémente avec elle elles ont été
remises en liberté elles auront
peut-être une amende mais c'est très
bien il faut sensibiliser je suis
persuasion parce qu'elle savait elles
sont contre le pétrole contre le gaz
elles sont en rapport pour que la vie
prime sur l'art et ça c'est intéressant
moi je les soutiens je leur dis bravo
voilà avec quel rapport entre le entre
le Mathieu Mathieu entre le pétrole et
la VAN GOGH les femmes qui ont rien
compris
soin de nos œuvres d'Arc de notre part
voilà c'est ça
les actions comme ça ça énerve tout le
monde
n'écoutent pas le sous texte sur ce
qu'ils voient c'est ce que jeunes filles
qui jettent un truc sur un Van Gogh et
n'essaye pas de comprendre ensuite ce
qui est dit encore donc en fait
c'est un coup d'épée dans l'eau leur
truc
leur action c'est elle jette de la soupe
et elle dise il y a des gens qui
aujourd'hui notamment en Angleterre ne
peuvent même plus se nourrir de soupe
tellement leur pouvoir d'achat avec lui
je trouve ça vraiment intéressant de
changer quelque chose
est-ce que ça a changé de bienveillance
de de bons sentiments en fait c'est une
sorte de progressisme à l'envers et en
fait c'est des ayatollas vertes en fait
et c'est une sorte de radicalité et la
radicalité c'est que l'extrême et ça ne
fait pas avancer la cause ça la
décrédibilise la cause on a l'impression
que c'est deux folles comme ça qui
mettent de la qui mettent de la soupe
sur un van box c'est débile et tu sais
qu'en fait pour moi la dérive en fait
c'est que aujourd'hui dans des pays où
il y a malheureusement ben des dérives
par exemple de terrorisme et tout ça ben
en fait ça passe toujours par là c'est à
dire qu'on efface l'art on éradicare
pour justement imposer sa cause et c'est
ça qui est dangereux voilà
moi je me suis endormie
moi je trouve que là ça fait quand même
fait ça fait quand même un petit rebelle
si tu as un vrai rebelle et que tu en as
dans le pantalon et bah tu détruis une
vraie œuvre et là c'est par exemple tu
as fait le truc et que tu es prêt à te
tuer d'accord
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
genre un style
des trucs
que vous parlez chez vos mère là
Johan spielber un peintre de quelle
époque contemporaine
[Rires]
je trouve que c'est une très bonne idée
en fait ils ont bien parce qu'ils ont
trouvé une soupe qui est dans les tons
du tableau original donc il y a une
forme de respect de l'artiste déjà
merci
le problème c'est que ces gens-là leur
cause des nobles et s'ils ne font pas
des actions coup de poing comme ça
personne ne les écoute donc ils sont
obligés de le faire et grâce à ça on
parle d'eux et ça reste une action
pacifique qui n'a pas eu de dégât le
tableau n'a quasiment pas été endommagé
donc bravo et le coup de poing il sert à
rien on en parle aujourd'hui donc on en
parle on parle de leur cause qui est
noble je suis désolé concrètement on en
fait quoi de cette cause
médiatique il faut justement on parle de
quoi elles ont fait ça est-ce que c'est
bien est-ce que c'est pas bien on parle
pas de la cause